Wow, that is really cool. And I love how
we can actually fly into the cabin as
well. That is sick. You've got this cozy
corner here, and then the bedroom, the
bathroom, and back to the cabin. All
right, so I'm going to show you guys how
to create a beautiful fully animated
website like this that sells for
thousands of dollars. I mean, look at
all these images here. They're all
created by AI with just a couple of
prompts. And this really looks like a
legit booking website. And I also just
found a new design skill that allows you
to transform any still image into a
drone fly-through video animation like
this. And I did this with Claude in just
less than three prompts. But I know
you're thinking, "Do we have to use
Fable 5 all the time? It's expensive and
it burns through my limit very, very
quickly." And you know what? I never
used Fable 5 for this project. In fact,
you don't even need to use expensive
models if you apply the tricks that I'm
going to show you in this video, so you
can still have the highest quality while
keeping your costs low. Yes, this looks
like a massive website project, and if
you've never done this before, it may
look intimidating, but it's actually
very, very simple. So, I'm going to
approach this tutorial for non-technical
people. I'm going to make it as simple
as possible to follow. So, if you know
how to chat with ChatGPT, you'll know
how to do this. So, let's dive in. Now,
before we build the site, I just want to
give you guys a brief on what we're
trying to build here. So, we got this
website for a cabin. So, basically like
an Airbnb, it's like a reservation site
where somebody can book a cabin for the
weekend. But look how the site is
actually designed. So, as I scroll my
mouse, it's got this fly-through
animation where the user can not only
look at the cabin, but they're going to
be able to see all the rooms inside as
well. So, imagine having this ability to
go through all these rooms and how
useful this will be for any type of real
estate photography. So, you can let the
user see and experience what it's like
inside the property before making a
decision, right? And I know this looks
very complicated to build, but Claude
will be doing all the heavy lifting here
while you just talk to it in plain
English. Now, we're going to use a
couple of tools to make everything
happen. Number one, we're going to use
Claude to be a director here, and
specifically Claude Design here to come
up with the colors, typography, and put
everything together nicely. And I'm
going to tell you why I'm starting with
Claude design and not Claude code. And
for this particular website, I actually
use Opus, and I also try to use the
latest GPT-5.6 to create the same
website, and I was able to get a very,
very similar quality. And number two,
we're also going to use Higgs Field as
the tool to generate all the images and
the videos in the website. And if you
guys are not familiar with Higgs Field,
it's where you can access all the latest
video models like Nano Banana, SeeDance,
GPT-2, all in one place. So, you don't
need a separate subscription to all
these models, and you can access
everything under one roof. And number
three, we're going to use this scale
here called Scroll World. It is a free
GitHub repo. It's been trending lately,
and it's basically a scale that allows
Claude to be able to use Higgs Field to
create this zoom-in fly-through
animation. And this is the cheat code
that makes this flying effect work. And
this will all make sense when I actually
show you how to do it. And finally, once
we build everything, I'm going to show
you how to deploy this website online.
So, whatever website you build, you can
get this life on the internet. You can
sell this for a client, or you can host
it for everyone to see. All right, so
let's get started, and I'm going to
start with Claude design here. So, if
you are seeing this for the first time,
you can go to claude.ai/design,
and it will pull up this platform here.
And by the way, this is a separate
platform from the desktop app, but
whatever you generate here is going to
use up the same credits from your
subscription. Now, you can definitely
use Claude code to build out the
website, but I always use Claude design
to create any type of design work,
whether it's websites, animations,
presentations. So, whatever project that
I'm building that has anything to do
with design, I always come back here.
And I have experimented with this
hundreds of times, comparing between
Claude code and Claude design, and
Claude design is more likely to produce
the design that I want because it is a
platform built for design work, and it
already has taste, right? So, this way
you're not going to waste tokens to keep
regenerating, and you don't even have to
use the most expensive model to get the
result that you want. So, this is kind
of my first trick in how I get the
design to look really good in the first
try by using a good design harness like
this. Now, before I paste in the prompt,
with any type of design work, you always
want to give it a reference, right? So,
so without giving it a reference, it's
like telling a builder, "Hey, I want you
to build me a nice house." You know,
nice is very subjective, so and it's
different for everybody. So, you want to
have some type of reference, you know,
maybe I saw this house on the street and
I like this Victorian style house. It's
got these colors, this many bedrooms,
and I want it to be this quality. And if
you give it that kind of reference,
obviously the builder is going to have
an easier time understanding your taste,
and it's more likely that it's going to
give you something that you want rather
than giving you something random. And
surprisingly, this is the step that a
lot of people don't actually take. They
just prompt Claude, "Hey, give me a
beautiful design for a reservation
website and come up with all the
colors." And that is going to be too
broad and too vague. Now, for design
inspiration, I like to go to Pinterest
or Dribbble. And for this particular
project, I typed in Airbnb in nature
just to get a couple of ideas on just to
see if I like any of these ideas. And I
actually landed on this particular
website style that I like here. So, I do
like the vibe, the blue and orange color
theme, and it even provided the font and
all the color palette as well. So, all I
need to do is take a screenshot of all
this and upload it to Claude design.
Now, of course, we're not going to copy
the exact design, but what we're doing
here is just take the colors, the
typography, the way that the buttons
look, and you want to communicate that
to Claude design. Now, of course, you're
also going to need the prompt. So, I've
already prepared the prompt earlier for
this. So, it is quite a detailed prompt
here, which I'm just going to grab and
copy right into Claude design. So, I'm
going to provide this entire resource
here for you guys down in the
description. So, if you want to recreate
this website, you can just follow all
the steps here in this landing page. But
basically, what this prompt is saying is
giving Claude instructions on generate
the images and videos, which is through
Higgsfield here. And what kind of
website am I building? This is basically
a a cabin reservation website, and the
colors that I'm looking for, and also
the type of rooms that I want in the
cabin. And by the way, I didn't write
all this. I asked Claude to come up with
all the descriptions of the rooms here
and come up with ideas, and it's just me
making the final decision whether I want
certain styles or not. Next, I've got
the hero video. So, this is the video
that you see in the top section, and
also the basically the sections that I
want to see on the website. So, not very
complicated, not super long, but
detailed enough for it to have context
in what I'm trying to build here. Now,
the next thing is you also want to
upload that screenshot of the reference
here, and then you want to choose the
model, which is 4.8, and I picked high
as the effort, and then you just hit go.
Now, while we're waiting, what we're
trying to build here is just the static
website, meaning the hero section does
not have any zoom-in animation. So,
we're just trying to build the base
structure of the website with this image
here, and also to build out the entire
website, like these sections down here
to the photo section with all
testimonials, and another booking page,
and the footer right here. So,
basically, this is step number one in
what we're going to build. And then,
once this is done, we're going to bring
this over to Claude code, where we're
going to install the scroll roll scale
and transform this hero section into a
fly-through animation. But, we're going
to start here first. All right, so this
is actually what we get after waiting
for just about 5 minutes. So, it's got
this hero section here, and all of these
are actually clickable as well. It's got
this date selector, and if I scroll
down, it's built out everything for me
exactly like I wanted. And without
Higgsfield, Claude is not going to be
able to generate all these images, the
room, the kitchen, all these shots,
because Claude does not have its own
image generation models. So, that's why
we needed Higgsfield to generate all
this for us. And notice that I didn't
even go to Higgsfield to prompt these
images myself, cuz we're actually using
the Higgsfield MCP connector. So, if you
click on your profile here under
connectors,
you can actually see that I have Higgs
Field MCP connected here. To connect
Higgs Field in the background and come
up with all the prompts, bring those
assets back to Cloud and stitch
everything nicely without us having to
manually think about the prompts, right?
So, that is a major time-saver, and all
you need to do is to have enough credits
in Higgs Field so that it will generate
all these videos and images for us. And
if you guys are curious, these are all
the images and videos that it was able
to create, and it was able to pick the
best one for our website. And if you're
doing this for the first time, you want
to go to MCP and CLI here, and you want
to just copy this URL here. Go and
browse directory, and under connectors,
you're going to click add custom
connector, and then you want to just
type Higgs Field, copy the URL here, and
you want to hit add, and that's it. I'm
not going to do that cuz I already have
this Higgs Field connector up and
running, but that's how easy it is to
set up. So, I'm going to go back to
Cloud Design here. Obviously, you can
make changes to this if you want to make
some edits. You can click on edit here.
If you don't like the positioning or you
want to change some words, you can do
that here. I think originally this was
not centered, so you can play around
with this alignment as well. So, you can
do whatever you want on the website
here. But once you're done with this,
and once you're ready to take this image
and transform it into a fly-through
video, we're going to bring this over to
Cloud Code. And we can do that easily by
going to share and saving the entire
file as a zip file. So, I'm going to
just save this and then hit export, and
it's going to save it in my computer.
Now, you always want to create a new
folder for every project that you create
with Cloud just to make everything
organized, and it's going to be easier
when it comes to deploying your website.
So, if you haven't already, just create
a folder here, name it whatever project
that you want, and then you want to just
move that zip file, cuz we're going to
get Cloud Code now to to study this file
here and start working on the website.
Now, before we go to Cloud Code, we're
going to grab this scale file. You want
to copy the URL and I'm just going to
ask Cloud Code to install the scale so
you can start creating this animation
here. So, what I did is basically just
type in a very simple prompt here. You
don't have to figure out on how to
install it. You can just say, "Can you
install the scale and provide the URL?"
And that's it. And it's going to study
that website and it's going to install
everything for you automatically. And
once you're done with that, you want to
open a new session and you want to make
sure that you're connected to that
folder where you save your zip file in.
So, in this case, it's connected to
Vesper 2. And what I did is just give it
this simple prompt. Check out the site I
created in this folder and use
/scrollworldscale
and this is how you would invoke that
scale to transform the hero section into
a flight scrolling animation. Tell me
your plan in what the shot will look
like before building anything. Study all
the design of the building and all the
rooms so all details can be presented
accurately in this video. So, Cloud Code
is actually not going to generate any
new images cuz we already did that here,
right? And we've got all the rooms here
as well. So, it's going to take all this
as a reference images of what the
interior of the cabin looks like and
create that drone fly-through video. So,
after it studied all the assets, the
images, it gave me a plan of how it's
going to create that video. And it even
gave me that shot of kind of the drone
path, what it's going to show scene by
scene. So, it's just a matter of me
looking through this and see if I
approve it or not. And without that
scroll world scale that we downloaded,
it's not going to be able to easily
understand our intent here. So, this
makes it a lot easier. And you can
actually see what it's doing. It's
pulling all the images from Higgsfield
here and it's trying to stitch
everything together without me having to
be involved here. And just in a few
minutes, it's done and it's giving me
this localhost URL that I can click and
I can preview it on my machine. And this
is what it looks like, right? So, if I
scroll down, you will see that it's able
to create this video animation with all
the rooms here and then going back to
this original shot and it kept the rest
of the website the same with the static
one, which is exactly what I want, and
that looks perfect to me. Now, of
course, there's a bit of back and forth
with Claude. I didn't get this
great-looking video in just one prompt.
I've noticed that it's not very
consistent in in terms of the images
that it generated. It's got the basic
idea of what we're trying to achieve,
but it added this outdoor sauna here
that we didn't ask for. And also,
because I didn't give it a floor plan of
the house, it's not going to be able to
know where the rooms are allocated,
right? So, it's doing this randomly. So,
I think if you give it a floor plan, and
you actually dictate on the drone flight
path, it should be able to give you a
more accurate representation of the
actual cabin. But considering that I
only did this in about 10 minutes, I
think this is already pretty amazing.
And one tip I can give you as well, you
always want to check what Higgs Field
generates for us in the back end. So,
you want to approve the images first
before you ask it to stitch it into a
video. And I actually found out why it
added that sauna on the patio, it's
because of this image here that has that
sauna here. That's why it's a little bit
confused. So, this is something that you
guys can check before you generate the
video. Now, if you guys want to recreate
this website, I actually provided a
resource page here where you can just
grab the instructions here, and these
are all the reference files that I gave
Claude Design, how to connect to Higgs
Field, all the tools that I used, the
image model, video models that I used in
Higgs Field, and also the entire prompt
is available here, completely free to
download in the description below. Now,
let's say you want to take your website
to the next level. Maybe you want to add
a simple animation like this, just like
what you see from the Notion website
here. Or maybe you want to add a
scrolling testimonial like this. Or
maybe you like this animation in the
pricing page here. Where do you actually
find these? So, I'm going to show you a
couple of websites where you can grab
these from, so you don't have to create
them from scratch. I'm going to show you
all that. But first, I want to show you
how to publish our website first, cuz
this is the part where a lot of people
get confused on how to set it up. What
if you want to make changes to your
site, etc. What is the easiest and most
seamless way to do this if you're not a
technical person? Now, for hosting, I'd
personally go with Hostinger. They are
the sponsor of today's video, but I've
personally built more than 10 websites
with them, and they're one of the most
reliable and affordable options when it
comes to hosting, and they've recently
launched an MCP connector to Cloud, so
you can actually have Cloud deploy your
website without you having to figure out
how to set up the back end of your
hosting, which can get a bit complicated
for someone who's not technical. So, all
you need to do is to set up the
connector once, and Cloud will handle
the rest, set up everything for you, and
you can just talk to it as if you had a
developer friend. So, I'm going to show
you how ridiculously easy this is. So,
first, you want to go to this website.
I'm going to provide the link in the
description below. You want to get a
plan. Now, if you already have a
Hostinger account, you can skip this
part. But, if you're new, you'll find
two options here. I would pick the left
one here if you're just getting started.
It's They're actually doing an 80% off
discount right now, which is just $3 a
month, and that gives you the ability to
host 50 websites, which is a lot of
websites. So, you want to click on
choose plan here, and once you land on
this page, you get to pick the period
that you want. Obviously, if you go with
the longer period, you get the best
pricing, you get the lowest price here.
And keep in mind that they do have a
30-day money-back guarantee, so for any
reason if you're not satisfied, you do
have that refund option. And also,
before you check out, you want to enter
my coupon code here, J Lee, hit apply,
and you actually get an additional 10%
off off your order, so it's even
cheaper. So, you want to hit continue,
and you want to finish your payment, and
then you will land on this dashboard
here. Now, to install the connector,
it's actually very easy. So, you want to
go back to Cloud Code here, and you want
to go to settings, and scroll down,
click on connectors, add custom
connector, and you want to call it
Hostinger, and you want to just paste in
this URL, mcp.hostinger.com,
and click add. And then, you want to hit
connect to authenticate yourself, and
then you want to allow that connection
to your account, and you're pretty much
good to go here. So, if I go down here,
I click the plus button, and I go to
connectors. I can verify that my
Hostinger connection is active. Now,
let's deploy the website. And it is very
simple to do so. You can simply write
this prompt here, Hostinger MCP
connector is active, deploy the site to
Hostinger, and hit enter. And then it's
going to do going to the Hostinger
backend, and it's going to build out and
push the site to Hostinger. Now, fast
forward, our site is deployed and
verified temporary Hostinger domain, and
if I click on this, there is our site
with the Hostinger URL here. And if I go
back to my Hostinger dashboard, let's
verify if the website's actually here.
So, if I go to websites here, I can see
that this is the website that it just
created, and it did that without me
having to set it up manually. So, the
connector is the key to all this. And if
you want to connect a domain, you can
just connect a domain from here. But
this temporary domain is pretty much all
you need if you're just showing this to
your client, or you just want to have a
temporary website. And I think one big
advantage to having a connector like
this is that whenever you want to make
changes to your website, you want to
make updates, and you don't have to
manually upload the files to Hostinger,
you can just ask Claude to push all the
updates to Hostinger on your behalf,
which saves a lot of time. All right, so
let's talk about some free resources. I
want to show you a couple of websites
that I normally go to to find
inspiration for design. So, we're going
to start with the website itself. So, if
you're a designer, you're probably
familiar with this website called
awwwards.com. So, this is basically a
website where you can see all the
websites that has received awards. So,
these are the best of the best websites
out there. So, for example, like this
one is a pet care service, and you've
got this awesome animated website, which
looks really, really cool. Or you got
this website selling pet food. You can
see there's a dog version and a cat
version as well, which is really cute.
And this is basically the website that I
go to whenever I want to get inspiration
for what good design looks like. Here
you can actually explore by category.
So, if you want to build e-commerce
websites, you can click on e-commerce.
Or or if you want to see something in
the fashion category or the mobile apps
category, you can filter the results
here. And if there's something you like,
copy the URL and give it to Cloud for
reference, like how I showed you in the
beginning of the video. Now, if you want
to add animated illustrations like this,
I like to go to LottieFiles here, where
there's a lot of free pre-made
illustrations or animations here. For
example, if I click on this one, this
looks like a Notion-style animation that
you can use for your website. And the
nice thing about LottieFiles here is
that you're able to actually change the
color here. So, you're not stuck with
this orange. So, maybe you want to
change this to a different color, you
can do that here by using the color
palette. And if you want to download
this, you can click on save animation
and you can download the code and hand
it over to Cloud Code to apply it to
your website. Now, if you want to add
sections, you want to add a section that
is scrolling like this, you can go to
21st Dev here. They do have some free
options and some paid options. So, you
can just copy the code here if you like
this one, and then paste it over to
Cloud Code, and it's going to be able to
use this style and merge it to your
website. And they've got a lot of other
things like a pricing section here,
which looks really cool, or some button
styles like this, which looks really
nice, or this cool-looking login page.
There's a lot of options here, and I'm
actually surprised that a lot of these
are actually free to use. All right, so
I hope you guys learned something from
this video. If you guys made it this
far, thanks again for watching till the
end. If you want to watch another video,
you want to click here, and I'll see you
guys later.